I think the only answer to that question
is probably Tina my name is Andrew ray I
host a youtube cooking show called
binging with babish where I recreate the
foods for movies and television binging
with babish a lot of people think that
my name is Oliver babish it's not Oliver
babish is a character from maybe three
episodes of The West Wing show that I
love I got started making the show just
because I bought a camera and lights and
I wanted to practice my food photography
and I thought it'd be fun to make a
burger from Parks and Rec that it just
sort of grew and grew and now it's my
full-time job so today we're making the
baby you can chive my car burger from
Bob's Burgers this was one of the most
requested burgers on the show and we're
gonna start with a step that most people
forget I'm gonna toast our buns be a
good guy and toast your buns for once
drop it in the buns I've never seen Bob
test his buns on the show but again this
is a man who cares about the quality of
the food namely who knows burgers and
then Bob knows his burgers knows the guy
to toast your bun everybody we have four
toasted buns let us fry it's gonna get a
little smoky in here folks the price you
pay for good food I'm just hitting these
with just salt and freshly ground pepper
that is all that they need because all
they want two minutes will slide right
off I started cooking when I was like 10
or 11 my mom taught me how to cook she
passed away when I was very young so
it's a nice way to just sort of feel
closer to her who's always been a huge
part of me and you know so it's film
it's a really nice way to to combine
those two things I'm very happy that
I've found a career that allows me to do
that all right call me it's done no real
cheese or condiments on this burger
except for a healthy dollop of
it's our friend those chives this
wouldn't be the baby you can chive my
car burger without lots and lots of
chives chopped it up it wouldn't be the
car burger without our fried pickle
wheels I'm getting ready to bread our
pickles here and I'm doing the classic
wet hand dry hand method for breading
these that way you only have one hand
touching the egg one hand touching their
flour we are fry when you're laying
things down and oil lay them down away
from you flip away from from you your
hands and your family and friends there
we go we have our fried pickle wheels
going to impale them just slip them
right in there that's is the baby you
can chive my car burger
vroom vroom I'm excited to see if people
like this much as I do know they're
they're fried pickles it's like a car it
has little wheels [ __ ] love fried
pickles so we have to guess the name of
the burger I'm not fun I know the name
of the baby you do baby you can chive my
car that is not a cartoon bird that's
like legit Chet the pickle is definitely
a very important addition icater
bouncing really nice like crunch I
really love sour cream and it's like the
perfect balance with the pickle you know
just up the chives I think we're trying
pph IVP really amazing this way by the
way that was a coolest burner I've ever
seen these are the kinds of barriers
that they make at Bob's Burgers why are
they not much as possible I really want
like Bob to serve me this because I
think the whole part of the Bob's
Burgers experiences the characters but
it's the diner it's the family I feel
like I just went to Bob's Burgers and I
ordered a burger and that's like my
dream I just can't believe they actually
taste like that I thought they're just
like crappy burgers
bring us more Andrew come back I don't
know someone anybody just a bob anymore